pleased to have back here one of my
favorite people that i'm so thrilled to
be able to call a friend and for the
first time on this program a hall of
famer officially
from espn and their nba coverage and the
terrific part in the interruption our
friend michael wilbon how are you sir
rich i'm pretty good how are you doing
i'm hanging in there so uh
there's so much going on my gosh i'm
just gonna dive right into it if you
don't mind
uh did you see what scottie pippen had
to say on our friend uh dp's show
today i i just i i just saw it uh
luckily thank you
for you i i was i was starting a sleep
marathon
uh last night when i got back from uh
from clippers sons and that
that but that was going to mean about 15
hours to catch up on days without it
and so i saw nothing on my own
thankfully your producer sent me this um
i say thankfully so i can be aware and i
just looked at it and
shook my head and i you know i don't i
don't know
you know i thought to scotty
occasionally
um and sometimes like during previous
season it'd be more than occasionally
because we would
work together on on rachel's show on the
jump and and
um known scotty for uh you know a long
long time i
i don't have any extra knowledge i have
no special
intel on this i looked at it and went
what like probably most people did so
i'm just
i'm just catching up and i know we're
all gonna have to react
to it and to whatever comes from it the
reactions to the reactions but
um yeah i'm just i'm just now seeing it
you know half an hour or so
so what were your boots on the ground
recollection of the coup coach
and pip and moment back in the day um
well look it was it was the
it was as dramatic as as
nba can get um i was
you know at the game um and immediately
i didn't know
i didn't realize that scotty was on the
court coming out of that timeout
right you know then you look look look
and you're wondering what's going on it
all happens in a flash
um but and there was you know there was
no social media of course to just
dissect it over and over and over again
a million times in the next you know 48
hours
and it was a it was a it was you know
scotty's low moment and it's certainly a
moment that i know he hated
having to relive during the last dance
um and i i did you know communicate with
him after that and i you know i was one
of the people who was critical
you know how could you you know how
could you not be i also
think that you know that moment
unfortunately not yeah i could talk to
scotty about it
that that that game that moment um
you know it it it colored him
for a long time and i thought i came to
think rich that
it it couldn't be the only thing that
that made us think a certain way about
scottie pippen because he did win
six he went one he didn't win two he won
six and and michael never won without
him
and scotty went on to play for a team
that should have been in the nba finals
you know the portland trailblazers with
a 19-point lead in the fourth quarter
of a of a game seven against the lakers
kobe and shaq
and that i don't know how that winning
and getting to the finals is interesting
how that might have changed further the
narrative but i thought we were away
from this
i thought i thought we were away from
this i thought i've i have said
written publicly and said to scotty i'm
not going to solely judge you
by a worse moment none of us wants to be
judged that way and his career has too
much else in it
the resume is too full and you know now
i hear this i don't
i don't i don't know what to think yet
michael wilbon here on the rich eisen
show
uh just for you know um completion
and for the moment uh pippin has
just tweeted out i'm just answering the
questions y'all
asking me you wanted the headlines you
got them dig deeper to find out why i
actually said what i said instead of
framing your questions to get
clicks it's all love
as with a heart emoji um
what do you think that means dig deeper
to find out i died i do
he's willing to learn not to do rich uh
put
too much into answers that come via
social media there's not discussion is
social media
i don't know what it means i can't i
can't tell you what it means i can react
to who i think phil jackson
is and was in my experience and i did
not
i was not around phil every day the
people who
the people who i will listen to on this
will be
uh and care what they say are the people
who played for phil and worked with him
so you know i i know those
men um obviously starting with michael
jordan
who will be asked i don't know how he
will weigh in but he will be at
right um and so many others ron harper
who i know will i want to hear what ron
harper
say i want to hear what bj armstrong has
to say i want to hear
what steve kerr you know and tony cu
coach
um i i wouldn't mind you know i've been
on a golf course a few times because
tony two coach which is a five hour fun
fest i
i would love to have four hours or five
hours
of access to tony today um so i i'm not
gonna i i
i don't i'm not i'm too old and too not
of the generation
to spend hours even minutes trying to
figure out what people are saying with
emojis and
you know secret phrases that are not
meant for me that meant for my 13 year
old son
i i i don't i i can't do that but
but i want i i want to hear
uh in in order to be able to engage
because we're gonna have to
but it it won't come i don't know what
all love means i mean
everybody utters these phrases these
days and it usually means nothing
and you have to get beneath it i guess
it is asking the
is but it's going to be asking the
questions of scotty as well as the men
who are on that team
right and so i guess the last one for
you on the subject before we go to the
here now then michael wilbon is what
what what
what can you tell me about the pip and
jordan relationship because it's clearly
something
that pippin also said to dan that the
the nba uh entertainment cameras that
picked up the huddle
in which michael was seeming to be
absolutely fine as well as be at the
forefront of setting ker up for a
winning
shot that we all know in the last dance
about
uh was a setup it was jordan knowing
that the cameras were there and that he
would control it for a documentary and
there just seems to be a lot of a lot of
confusing statements
but it was all they have they have a
complex they've had a complex
relationship i don't that's any
we saw that in the documentary uh which
explains it much more than any
you know individual statement as well we
saw that and
and you know there was a time when they
didn't i you know i don't know that it
was
ever in my view hostile it was just they
are very different people they had a
complex relationship in which michael
we know from the last dance how to mandy
michael just
scotty pippen but we know of steve kerr
you know we we know those stories now um
and i i i believe
i i know that some of that the reliving
of that
hurts god i that i know
um that it hurt him the re the reliving
of these moments
that hurt in the beginning if
if they were complex and they heard 30
years ago then
we know what they must feel like 30
years later um
they were never the best of friends i
mean there were people on the team
that michael was closer to bj armstrong
i mean there were people on the team
that
you know the irony of scotty and cu
coach and that whole thing in the
olympics and the dream team
is it's got that that tony coach and
scotty became very close
um and you know when you mentioned
scottie too tony he would
you always call it a pip and he'd have a
smile on his face and
scotty became very much his big brother
um
as i interpreted from both of them
um so but these things are not they're
not going to change
right the relationships that you can't
undo the relationships you can't
redo the relationships there's no
mulligan
you know um pun intended on these
relationships they were complex a year
ago
when we finished watching the last dance
right about now or maybe a month earlier
right and um so this is what it is
and there was less examination of phil
and the guys i mean michael has told me
to get to phil for a second um he told
me that that the
three most important in his life and i
quoted him somewhere doing this in the
washington post
um in life time that the three most
important in his life
were his father dean smith and
and phil jackson um and in the context
we i have to go back and get the context
i don't know if the context was
well it couldn't be solely basketball
because his dad is a headliner and
obviously we know that that
comes as no secret um so
that relationship maybe was less
conflict i don't i don't
i don't know that all of us know maybe
chicago beat riders know a ton
about phil's relationship with scotty
other than
1.8 seconds maybe michael wilbon here
on the rich eisen show pardon the
interruption and of course the nba
coverage that we're
we're locked into uh with it appearing
to be
michael is it fair to say we're we got
sun's bucks uh on the horizon
to use the phrase okay no
you won't do that no you won't go there
i mean i i think that
i think that look i picked the sons in
seven um and i think this you know the
come on the clippers without kawhi
leonard are
reduced there's no question about that
it's like the sun's without
chris paul with chris paul even injured
during that laker series
or without him for the first two games
of this series and i thought the
flippers had to get
at least one of those two games and they
didn't to win to beat
uh the sons in this series and the
clippers didn't do that but
and then i don't trust milwaukee i've
been following this for three years i've
been watching milwaukee for three years
they do the oddest most bizarre thing
some me would say
dumb when people are just jacking up
threes every
few games they just not even sometimes
back-to-back games i don't trust the
bucks i have to see them win it
atlanta should have won that game last
night atlanta should be up 2-1 and i'm
not hearing that atlanta can't
you know tony my partner in crime
says you know when they lost game one he
goes they're not they're not losing
another game milwaukee's gonna sweep i
know charles
so two of the people i'm closest to in
life uh when talking about sports
believe atlanta
was not gonna win another game i don't
believe that because i don't trust the
milwaukee bucks
um there's too many bizarre things over
the last few seasons and particularly
this
postseason and the clippers rich they're
tough
they're tough minded they're tough
physically they're not better without
kawhi
nobody's gonna say that they're not as
good without kawhi
but they're tough they are um
and so i don't know i i think the suns
will win tonight
but i'm not loading it up i think the
sun look put it this way
i believe the suns will win this series
am i
ruling out further drama no i'm not i
think they'll win the series i
think they'll win tonight but this is
going to be it's like it was an alley
fight the other night that was the 1980s
basketball it was broke out yeah
and so when you have that kind of thing
and the other team is willing to
initiate and engage in that
yeah i don't know i think there's
there's more drama to be seen
maybe it'll just be a close son's win
tonight it can be that way too
well i guess i'm not i'm not counting it
up i guess the thing that's most jarring
about the bucks is can you name me
another team where the clear
star of the team the mvp of a league
uh twice in a row isn't the closer
of the team yeah i mean it's rare i'd
have to i mean i'd have to examine
every single championship team
right and i was trying to figure out you
know was it you know was it kenny smith
and not a keem
was it so there's some of that i mean i
don't know sometimes it was ginobili
on those spro on those spurs teams right
or earlier you know it wasn't
necessarily
david robinson was a start early and
then it became duncan and then sometimes
it was genomics so it floated and those
are four hall of famers on that team
obviously
it's rare it's rare rich to your point
and in this case it can't be
because you can't have a guy going four
four what was he last night four for ten
yeah foul shooting it's crazy so you
know it can't be
here's the other reason look i i'm sure
that
how how how do you have a team that you
have a guy like bobby portis who's 610
who has been in the league for i don't
know seven years something like that 70
and you don't even play him you straight
games in the series and you're playing
against kevin durant
how do you know how do you if you know
how do you not play him
at all not one second you're looking for
long
tall athletic experienced bodies to even
help out even
if it's a foul kevin durant even if it's
getting his way accidentally
and you don't play him for three games
after he's helped you sweep the first
series
i don't i i i don't understand anything
that milwaukee does or anything he is a
coat hands but i don't understand
anything they do and so my reaction i'm
not going to say they're bad at it i'm
not
they're not bad at it they're they're
they're capable of winning a
championship
i don't understand what the hell they're
doing most nights
michael wilbon here on the rich eisen
show what's your what's your
uh viewpoint of ben simmons viability as
a sixer moving forward
i don't see it and i don't and i don't
wish it on them
right and i'm i'm conflicted here rich i
mean doctor
was a friend not a friend i'm
one of my good friends all right and i'm
biased i am biased toward
doc rivers in every episode of these
things
going back more years than i care to
admit and when i joke with him i i'm not
joking
that i say people say how long you don't
block us well i've known doc a lot
longer because he had no reason to know
who i was on any playground
or pickup court ever in life i i knew
who he was
and so i root for doc right
i don't i don't i don't wish for that on
doc rivers
ben simmons is a talent i had to deal
with my own 13 year old wise guy
son who's you know plays point guard and
he loves basketball
he loves his own father and he came to
me about
six weeks ago he said dad ben simmons is
a liability
and i said like shut up and go to your
room without dinner
that's the dumbest thing i've ever heard
what were you gonna really you want to
play basketball that's
your your hot date that the incident is
a liability this went on
for weeks at my house i had to go to him
last week and say
okay you can come out of your room
[Laughter]
because i i joke but the story is real i
see about my son saying that
and my reaction initially to him but
rich this
is how can you he needs a new he needs a
change of scenery
i agree he needs a change i agree and i
think there are places where he can have
that change
and somebody who's got to impress upon
him um
i i picked out golden state as an
example just as an example i'm not
trying to do
a warrior's bidding and bob meyer's
bidding and steve kerr's dealing
but that's the place where it seems to
me that the roster the guys on the
roster
between the combination of just
intellect basketball intellect
tough love soft love whatever you want
to call it you know having
a combination of you know people that
you know are in that
in that organization that might be a
place where he could
prosper relatively quickly again
but i don't i don't see it in philly
in philly of all places silly
i mean i mean i would even wish that on
ben who seems to be just a
nice guy i mean i've met him a couple
times i haven't had a ton of exposure to
him privately
but i just don't wish that on him and i
wish him to get his career
redirected in the way that we knew it
already
well you know i don't know if this is
apples and oranges um because you know
cam spent many
you know a couple more years in carolina
but i don't think it was the same
the minute that in super bowl 50 the
ball was on the ground and he kind of
flinched it
and it all you know the game was kind of
over anyway denver was going to win that
super bowl
but yeah it you know and then his
reaction to the media afterwards he
wasn't the same quarterback there i mean
he did have half a season before he got
hurt
i don't know if it's apples and oranges
but but but simmons passing up that dunk
passing up that dunk and passing it off
i mean that was that's it yeah
yeah i think his was more psychological
than but i could be wrong
it's an interesting analogy you raised
because i got i hadn't thought about
playing years
i i by that point i thought that even
though that was a few years ago
he even put so much punishment the
flinch was actually it was
physical more than maybe psychological
it was like what is good
you know what is going to come when you
get in that position with von miller
he was in right yeah and and who i don't
remember who else was in the potential
scrum coming at him
this is like a bending physical i mean
it's it's it's a
it's psychological i mean there's no i
mean yeah we're all playing you know
you know psychology 101 arms your
quarterback you okay fine
but when you don't dunk the ball because
you're worried about being filed by
trey young then you you you don't want
to be fouled this is not even open for
debate
you don't want to be fouled in that
moment because you don't want to have to
go to the free throw line
and so he's there's so many things there
can he be helped and could it work in
philly
yes i'm not saying it cannot work in
philadelphia i'm not saying that
i'm saying i don't wish that recovery on
him in philadelphia
i don't i mean what you know you know
it's rich no i don't you
know what that's like in that town of
course especially since
even if he does stay there and have a
terrific regular season all it takes is
one moment like that in his first
playoff game and it all it's all back to
square one like right there i don't wish
it on him i don't wish it on doc i just
think
that can be a parting of the way there
philadelphia the sixers can get on
with what you know what they're trying
to do is win a championship
and ben simmons can get on with his
career i i just think that now
we look for so many things to be you
know hot takes and
remedy through you know i i don't
believe in it i
just think he needs a fresh start well i
i i i appreciate the call
michael like in terms of these playoffs
it's been so much fun to watch
and seeing the fans back in the building
has been terrific and
my favorite my favorite shot of the
playoffs so far
was caught by i guess a fan in the
stands in phoenix
just taking the camera fans are going
crazy to the right and to the left
there's you
and stephen i think with stephen a had
like a cup of coffee or something like
that or you had the coffee
and i know there's no cheering in the
press box or anything but you you
you your jaws were just like hitting the
floor i love that
that was that jaw that's for now oh my
tonight is going to be so interesting
there rich but that was
it's if you can't i mean i was screaming
at stephen
in the moments leading up to the play
right before the inbounds during the
interminable timeouts that came with
that
that's right that that made 90 seconds
take 33 minutes
i was screaming at stephen a aten to the
rim it's eight in the rim and he was
saying no you can still go to booker
like i could be happy to go to booker
with a full you know two seconds left
with eight into the rim eight into the
rim
i'm screaming it it doesn't mean i think
it's going to actually work
and when the game is just what you you
know you're sitting there drawing it up
like you're
talking like with like you and i are now
just keeping you and me on a tech chain
or on the phone
right and i'm screaming to the rim and
it's just so
shocking to have it happen in that
building in that way and that noise in
that way
it wasn't a west coast building in that
moment i mean people can
act if they want like all the buildings
sound loud at the end they don't
madison square garden boston philly
chicago detroit
they don't sound the same as la and
phoenix they don't
they sound exponentially louder and more
desperate and more frantic
and that they're not cheers or screams
in those buildings and that's how
phoenix sounded
in this absence of you know championship
or even playoff basketball we're showing
the shot right there we just showed the
shot right there that's still there
so did you at least before i let you go
did you at least turn to stephen and go
i told you did you give him a
no he said actually we immediately went
on the air
rich and i don't know if we're wrong
with scott van pelt first we were on
nowhere i guess we were on uh the la
sports center first with stan
and stephen a said i just said wilbon
screaming in my ear i'm
almost deaf now aiden to the rim which i
i did
i got that right but i love it rest of
it is like oh my goodness what else can
happen
that's what i'm saying rich don't rule
out drama tonight
i just think there's something left in
this alley fight of a series that we're
gonna
tomorrow be reacting to i don't even
know i'm not even gonna have a
prediction tonight i don't know
i just think it's more dramatic i'll be
tuned in tonight michael thanks for the
time
greatly appreciate it you have me always
appreciate it please i i cherish this i
really do thanks for the call michael
let's do well you bet you too that's
michael wilbon everybody the real mike
wilbon on twitter he's a must follow
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here